>> ONE REASON THAT STUNS ME IS
OBVIOUSLY THE INFORMATION THAT I
INFORMATION THE FBI ALREADY HAD.
MY STORY IS ABOUT THE FBI'S OWN
INVESTIGATION.
SO IT SEEMS A LITTLE ODD THAT
THEY WOULD BE CITING THE YAHOO!
NEWS STORY ABOUT THE MATTER THAT
BEFORE I WAS EVER BRIEFED BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
>> Sean: THAT WAS MICHAEL IS A
COUGH LATE LAST WEEK REVEALING
HIS SHOCK THAT THAN YAHOO NEWS
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AS
WE MENTIONED EARLIER VOTED TO
RELEASE THE MEMO GOES TO THE
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
YOU GOT A GREAT VOTE OF SUPPORT
AND ANYBODY THAT BELIEVES IN
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY.
IN THE LEAD UP TO YOUR MEMO,
THAT WOULD HURT OUR INTELLIGENCE
IN ANY WAY.
CORRECT, SIR?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SEAN.
I THINK THAT WAS IS A
COUGH, THE TAPE YOU JUST RAN.
THAT IS ILLUMINATING.
FRONT OF REPORTERS.
YOU HAVE THE REPORTER HIMSELF
ADMITTING IT.
THIS IS BIG NEWS.
I ACTUALLY CAUGHT SOME OF THIS
LAST WEEK AND TWEETED IT OUT.
THIS IS WHAT THE FBI USE TO
COOPERATE DOSSIER, WHICH IS
VERY, VERY DANGEROUS, TO TAKE
POLITICAL DIRT THAT WAS PAID FOR
BY THE HILLARY CAMPAIGN AND USE
USE IT TO OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE MEMO, YOU ACTUALLY GO
THROUGH WITH THAT, IT RAISES
COURT, AND REPRESENT A TROUBLING
BREAKDOWN OF THE LEGAL PROCESS
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHAT IS SERIOUS ABOUT
IT.
FISA APPLICATION AND SUBSEQUENT
RENEWALS, FOUR TIMES, THEY NEVER
INFORMED THE FISA COURT THAT
THIS MONEY WENT TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
MORE SO, THEY NEVER INFORMED THE
COURT THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
WAS MEETING WITH JOURNALISTS.
I THINK THE COURT COULD HAVE
KNOWN THAT.
SEND A LETTER TO THE COURT.
WE DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL BE
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT, BUT WE ARE
GOING TO ASK THE COURT WHETHER
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WAS PRESENTED
VERBALLY TO THE COURT AND TO SEE
IF THAT WAS TRANSCRIBED.
>> Sean: THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE.
IF THEY KNEW -- WE KNOW IT WAS
NOT VERIFIED.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, YOU EVEN
PUT IN YOUR MEMO THAT THE FBI
THEMSELVES, THEY SAID THEY WERE
ONLY IN THE INITIAL STAGES OF
VERIFICATION.
SO THEY WOULD PRESENT SOMETHING
THAT WAS UNVERIFIED THAT WE KNOW
IT IS PAID FOR BY ONE POLITICAL
PARTY TO CREATE A WARRANT
AGAINST ANOTHER PARTY DURING AN
ELECTION AND A PRESIDENT-ELECT.
>> I THINK THE BIGGER PROBLEM,
CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS TOTALLY
MISSED OR IN THIS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THAT SHE WAS
ON THE OTHER TRUE, IF
DONALD TRUMP, GEORGE BUSH,
KARL ROVE PAID FOR INFORMATION,
AND GEORGE W. BUSH'S FBI OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE OBAMA
CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE TALKING TO RUSSIA --
BY THE WAY, WHICH REALLY HAPPEN.
THEY WERE TALKING TO RUSSIAN
BACK IN 2008, OPEN UP A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION USING DIRT AND DUG
UP AND PAID FOR BY THE RNC AND
GEORGE W BUSH SUPPORTERS?
FOLLOWING AROUND KARL ROVE AND
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY EMBARRASSING.
I'M ALMOST FLABBERGASTED.
I THOUGHT, AT LEAST, THERE WOULD
BE SOME OUNCE OF CREDIBILITY
LEFT.
BUT THERE REALLY ISN'T ANY.
>> Sean: ULTIMATELY, STEELE,
UNVERIFIED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MEMO THAT
CAME OUT OF CHUCK GRASSLEY'S
COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY, GOES ON
TO SAY THAT STEELE GATHERED MUCH
RUSSIA.
IF I PUT THE TWO MOMENTS DON'T
LIKE MEMOS TOGETHER, YOURS FROM
FRIDAY, HILLARY P PAID FOR
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA, UNVERIFIED,
SIR, ARE THERE CRIMES COMMITTED
HERE?
>> YOU CAN'T REALLY MAKE THIS
YOU HAVE A CAMPAIGN WHO HIRED A
LAW FIRM, WHO HIRED FUSION GPS,
WHO HIRED A FOREIGN AGENT, WHO
GOT INFORMATION FROM THE
RUSSIANS ON ANOTHER CAMPAIGN.
IT SEEMS LIKE A COUNTER
INVESTIGATION SHOULD HAVE BEEN
OPENED UP AGAINST THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN WHEN THEY GOT A HOLD OF
THE DOSSIER.
BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN EITHER.
AND YOU MENTIONED
SENATOR GRASSLEY HAS DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB HERE, SEAN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN,
MYSELF AND MY COMMITTEE, A LOT
OF CREDIT WE'VE DUG UP.
PHENOMENAL THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE
PROCESS.
I THINK HE DESERVES A LOT OF
CREDIT.
>> Sean: THIS GUY, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, IS A GUY WHO HAS A
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIM NOT
BEING THE PRESIDENT.
SO HE HAS HIS OWN POLITICAL
MOTIVATION IN ALL OF THIS.
>> AND, SEAN, THAT ALSO WAS NOT
PRESENTED TO THE COURT.
>> Sean: WELL, I MEAN...
QUESTION THIS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, THAT ALL THEY ARE SAYING
IS, WELL, ON THE FISA
APPLICATION, THERE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN A FOOTNOTE TO SAY THAT
THERE IS SOME POLITICAL
PAINTING, AND THAT'S IT?
ABOUT BEING PAID FOR BY CLINTON,
NONE OF THIS CAME OUT TO THE
COURT?
IS IN THAT DELIBERATELY
DECEIVING THE COURT,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> NOT ONLY THAT, THEY CONTINUE
OBFUSCATION THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE CONTINUED TO DO THROUGHOUT
THIS INVESTIGATION IS LEAK
SOMETHING ELSE TO DO A PRESS
THAT IS BASICALLY PART OF THEIR
OWN TEAM, THEY RUN A STORY THAT
IS BASED ON SOMETHING PARTIALLY
THE EVIDENCE.
>> Sean: I'M SORRY.
SO I
>> PART OF THE REASON WE KNOW
I'M RIGHT, THE RELENTLESS
ATTACKS ON ME, TREY GOWDY.
MEMO.
THEY COME TO THE CONCLUSION.
WHAT DID THEY SAY FOR TEN DAYS
QUICK SMACK THEY SAID THAT OUR
MEMO CAME TO ALL SORTS OF
CONCLUSION.
OUR MEMO DIDN'T COME TO ANY
CONCLUSIONS.
OUR MEMO LISTED ON THE FACTS.
OUR MEMO, PEOPLE WILL SEE, THEY
ACTUALLY COME TO CONCLUSIONS.
THEY HAVE PERSONAL ATTACKS ON
MYSELF AND CHAIRMAN GOWDY.
ONLY ONE REPUBLICAN WAS ALLOWED
TO SEE IT.
USE AND THE LAWYER TREY GOWDY,
THAT'S WHERE THE INFORMATION
CAME FROM.
I'M VERY INTERESTED.
AT THE HEART OF THIS, YOU HAVE
NELLIE OHR, BRUCE OHR'S WIFE,
FOR FUSION GPS THAT IS BUILDING
THE DOSSIER AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR A McCADE,
TESTIFYING BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
IN 2017, THERE WOULD BE NO
WARRANT WITHOUT THE DOSSIER.
MY SOURCES HAVE TOLD ME THAT HE
AUTHENTICITY OF THAT, OUR
CORRECTNESS OF THAT.
I WAS TOLD HIS ANSWER IS EVEN
HOURS OF TESTIMONY, TREY GOWDY
INTERVIEWED HIM FOR 16 HOURS.
WE DID A SHORT SUMMATION IN ONE
SENTENCE.
WHAT IS THE MAJOR REVELATION WE
DISCOVERED WITH MR. McCAIN?
THAT IS WITHOUT THE DOSSIER,
THEY WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO GO TO THE PFIZER COURT
AND GET A WARRANT.
THAT'S THE POINT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO RELEASE
EXECUTIVE SESSION TRANSCRIPTS IN
THIS.
THERE WAS NO NEED FOR IT.
WE SURMISED EIGHT HOURS, TRY TO
ANYWAY --
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS --
>> WE JUST HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
PLAY THE GAME WITH THEM,
UNFORTUNATELY, THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DROP OUT LITTLE
PIECES OF PHONY INFORMATION.
WE HAVE TO TRY TO CORRECT THE
RECORD.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU SAY THERE'S
ABOUT FOUR MORE MEMOS COMING, A
LOT IS COMING, SIR?
>> MORE ON THAT.
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
CONFUSION.
FISA AND OTHER MATTERS.
THIS IS A VERY BROAD
INVESTIGATION LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT AREAS.
THE SENSE OF THE 11G PROCESS WE
FOLLOWED IN THE HOUSE, BUT WE DO
HAVE AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION
WILL REMAIN PRIVATE, PUBLIC ON